The way I solved this puzzle was to first align my right hand to the directions
given in the beta, X south, Z west, and Y up. If I could do it, then I know the
system was right-handed. Easy enough, my right hand aligns just fine. If I try
the same thing with my left hand, I can get 2 out of 3 axis to align but the
third is always in the opposite direction. So, we know the beta version of
minecraft used right hand coordinates. I could solve the second half of the
question by reorienting my right hand and again, noticing that the fingers can
properly align with the axes. So, it is also right-handed. However, you don't
really need to use your hands to figure this out. What happened within the world
itself was simply that the sun started to rise form a different direction. None
of the world's data had changed at all. The only thing that had changed was our
perception of which direction was east. Since the world was the same as before,
the underlying coordinate system itself had not changed. Realizing this, I could
conclude that the released version is still right-handed, just like the beta,
but it never hurts to check with my right hand.